Hay un pequeño país enclavado en el Himalaya,
lejos de estas bonitas montañas, donde la gente
del Reinado de Bután ha decidido hacer algo diferente,
que consiste en medir la Alegría Nacional Bruta
en vez del Producto Nacional Bruto.
Y ¿por qué no?
A fin de cuentas, la felicidad no es un privilegio de los pocos afortunados,
sino un derecho humano básico que merecen todos.
Y ¿qué es la felicidad?
La felicidad es la libertad de elección.
La libertad de elegir dónde vivir,
qué hacer, qué comprar, qué vender
de quién, a quién dónde y cómo.
¿De dónde viene la elección?
Y ¿quién tiene derecho a expresarlo y cómo lo expresamos?
Bueno, una manera de expresar la elección es a través del mercado.
Los mercados que operan bien ofrecen opciones y al final
la habilidad que uno tiene de expresar su búsqueda de la felicidad.
A la gran economista india, Amartya Sen, se le concedió el Premio Nobel
porque demostró que la hambruna no se trata tanto de
la disponibilidad de productos alimenticios, sino de la habilidad de adquirir
o otorgarse el derecho a esa comida a través del mercado.
En 1984, en lo que sólo se puede considerar uno de los
crímenes más grandes de la humanidad casi mil millones de personas murieron de hambre
en el país donde nací, Etiopía.
No porque no hubiera suficiente comida,
de hecho había comida excedente
en las regiones fértiles del sur del país,
sino porque en el norte, la gente no podía acceder a
o otorgarse el derecho a esa comida.
Eso fue un un momento decisivo para mi vida.
La mayoría de africanos, con mucho, son agricultores.
Y la mayoría de los agricultores de África son, en conjunto,
pequeños agricultores en cuanto a la tierra que utilizan y
muy pequeños agricultores en cuanto al capital que tienen a su disposición.
Hoy día la agricultura africana está entre los sectores menos subvencionados del mundo.
Sólo el siete por ciento de las tierras de cultivo de África son irrigadas.
comparado con el 40 por ciento en Asia.
Los granjeros africanos sólo utilizan aproximadamente 22 kilos de fertilizantes por hectárea,
comparado con los 144 de Asia.
La densidad del tráfico es seis veces mayor en Asia que en el África rural.
Hay ocho veces más tractores en América Latina,
y tres veces más tractores en Asia que en África.
El pequeño agricultor en el África de hoy vive con pocas opciones,
y de ahí con poca libertad.
Su manera de ganarse la vida está predeterminada
por las condiciones de extrema pobreza.
Él viene al mercado cuando los precios están más bajos,
con los escasos frutos de su duro trabajo, justo después de la cosecha,
porque no tiene más remedio.
Ella regresa al mercado
unos meses después, cuando los precios están más altos, en lo que llamamos
la estación mala, cuando la comida es escasa,
porque tiene que alimentar a su familia y no le queda más remedio.
La cuestión importante es, ¿cómo se puede desarrollar mercados en la África rural
para aprovechar el poder de la innovación y el espíritu emprendedor
que hemos conocido antes?
Otro economista distinguido, Theodore Schultz,
ganó el Premio Nobel en 1974 por demostrar que los agricultores
son eficaces, pero pobres.
De hecho, quiso decir que los agricultores son seres racionales
y que les interesan las ganancias tanto como los demás.
Bueno, ahora no nos hace falta
más Premios Nobel para saber que los agricultores quieren una oportunidad justa
en el mercado, y quieren ganar dinero, como todos los demás.
Y una cosa queda clara, por lo menos ahora sabemos
que África está abierta a los negocios.
Y esa empresa es la agricultura.
Hace más de dos décadas, el mundo le insistió a África que se debía
liberalizar los mercados, que las economías debían someterse a programas de ajuste estructural.
Esto significaba que los gobiernos tenían que dejar de participar
del proceso de comprar y vender,
lo cual hicieron de manera bastante ineficaz,
y permitir que el mercado privado hiciera su magia.
Bueno, ¿qué pasó a lo largo de los últimos 25 años?
¿África se alimentó?
¿Nuestros agricultores se hicieron actores comerciales altamente productivos?
Pienso que estamos todos aquí
probablemente, porque sabemos que de hecho, África es la única región
del mundo en que se pronostica subirán las tasas de hambre y desnutrición
durante los próximos 10 años.
Donde la factura por importación de comida es ahora el doble
de lo que fue hace 20 años.
Donde la producción de comida per capita
se ha estancado, y donde el uso de fertilizantes ha disminuido en vez de aumentar.
¿Por qué no alcanzaron los mercados de agricultura las expectativas de los consumidores?
Las reformas del mercado que impulsaron el mundo occidental,
y he pasado unos 15 años viajando por todo el continente
e investigando sobre los mercados agrícolas y he entrevistado
a comerciantes de entre 10 y 15 países del continente, cientos de comerciantes,
intentando comprender qué salió mal con nuestra reforma del mercado.
Y me parece que es posible que las reformas
descartaran el grano de la paja.
Como su agricultura,
los mercados de África se encuentran con financiación muy insuficiente y funcionan de manera ineficaz.
Sabemos de nuesto trabajo en el continente
el costo de las transacciones requeridas para alcanzar el mercado,
y los riesgos de hacer negocios en mercados de agricultura rurales.
son sumamente altos.
De hecho, sólo un tercio de la producción agrícola
de África llega a alcanzar el mercado.
Los mercados de África son débiles no sólo porque la infraestructura es débil
en cuanto a los caminos y las telecomunicaciones, sino también porque
las instituciones del mercado necesarias están prácticamente ausentes como
informaciones del mercado, como grados y estándares
y maneras fiables de comunicar a compradores y vendedores.
A causa de esto, los compradores y vendedores normalmente hacen negocios en círculos pequeños,
en redes estrechas de personas que conocen y de las cuales se fían.
Y a causa de eso, a medida que el grano cambia de dueño,
y he encontado que cambia de dueño cuatro, cinco veces en
su trayectoria desde el granjero hasta el consumidor,
cada vez que cambia de dueño, y lo he visto en todas partes de la África rural,
también cambia de saco.
Y me pareció increíblemente extraño.
Y de verdad me di cuenta de que era porque, como me dirían los comerciantes
una y otra vez, es la única manera de saber que el producto es bueno
en cuanto a la cantidad y calidad del producto.
Y eso tiene implicaciones enormes
en la capacidad de los mercados de responder de manera eficaz a los indicadores de precios,
y a situaciones en las cuales hay déficits, por ejemplo.
También hay muchas implicaciones en cuanto al costo.
He determinado que el 26 por ciento del margen de marketing
se puede deber al solo hecho de que como hay una ausencia
de grados y estándares e informaciones del mercado,
hay que cambiar los sacos constantemente.
Y esto conduce a muy altos costos de gestión.
Por su parte, los pequeños agricultores, que producen la mayor parte de nuestra producción agrícola en África
vienen al mercado prácticamente sin información, ciegos.
Confiando en que van a tener
alguna demanda por sus productos alimenticios,
totalmente a merced de los comerciantes
en el único mercado, el mercado más cercano que conocen,
en donde son incapaces de negociar mejores precios para reducir su riesgo.
Hablando del riesgo, hemos visto que la fluctuación de los precios
de las cosechas en África es la más alta en el mundo.
En África, los pequeños granjeros sufren lo peor de este riesgo.
De hecho, en mi opinión, no hay una región del mundo ni una época histórica
en que se haya esperado que los agricultores sufran el grado de riesgo en el mercado
que tienen que sufrir los agricultores de África.
Y, en mi opinión, no hay otro lugar en el mundo
que haya desarrollado su agricultura en condiciones de riesgo
similares a las que los agricultores de África se enfrentan hoy día.
En Etiopía, por ejemplo, los precios del maíz
varían hasta el 50 por ciento de año a año.
Este tipo de riesgo en el mercado es alucinante y tiene implicaciones directas
no sólo en los incentivos que tienen los granjeros de invertir
en tecnología de más productividad, tales como semillas y fertilizantes modernos,
sino también implicaciones directas en la seguridad alimentaria.
Por ejemplo, entre 2001 y 2002
los agricultores del maíz de Etiopía produjeron dos años de cosecha.
Eso, a su vez, a causa del débil sistema de marketing
condujo a una disminución del 80 por ciento de los precios del maíz en el país.
Por eso, para algunos agricultores, no era rentable cosechar grano de los campos.
Y calculamos que aproximadamente 300.000 toneladas de grano
fueron dejadas en los campos para pudrirse en los primeros meses de 2002.
Menos de seis meses más tarde, Etiopia anunció una gran crisis alimentaria,
de la misma severidad de la que tuvimos en 1984, 14 milliones de personas en riesgo de desnutrición.
Lo que también pasó aquel año
es que en las regiones donde las lluvias eran buenas, y en donde los agricultores
habían producido grano excedente antes, habían decidido
retirarse del mercado de fertilizantes, no utilizar fertilizantes,
y de hecho habían disminuido el uso de fertilizantes el 27 por ciento.
Este es un ejemplo trágico de desarrollo atrofiado,
o una revolución verde en ciernes que no siguió adelante.
Y esto no sólo se aplica a Etiopía,
sino que pasa una y otra vez, en todas partes de África.
No estoy aquí para lamentar la situación, o para retorcerme las manos.
Estoy aquí para decirles que estamos por cambiar.
El África de hoy no es el África que esperaba ayuda.
o prescripciones típicas de expertos extranjeros.
África ha aprendido, o está aprendiendo, bastante lentamente,
que los mercados no se crean.
En los años 80, estaba muy de moda
hablar de encontrar el mejor precio.
Había un libro muy influyente sobre este tema,
que se trataba principalmente de retirar los gobiernos del mercado.
Ahora nos damos cuenta de que perfeccionar los mercados no sólo es cuestión de
incentivos, sino también de invertir en infrestructura rentable,
y en las instituciones que son apropiadas y necesarias para crear
las condiciones para desatar el poder de motivación en el mercado.
Cuando las condiciones son buenas, sabemos y nos damos cuenta de que
esa innovación está tan lista para explotar en la África rural,
como en cualquier otro lugar.
Hace casi tres años, decidí dejar mi cómoda carrera
como economista de alto rango del Banco Mundial en Washington
para regresar al país donde nací, Etiopía,
después de casi 30 años en el extranjero.
Tomé esta decisión por una sola razón.
Después de haber pasado más de una década
mejorando mi comprensión, estudiando y tratando de convencer a los políticos y a los donantes
de lo que salía mal en los mercados agrícolas de África,
decidí que era hora de hacer algo para cambiar la situación.
Actualmente, encabezo, en Etiopía, una nueva iniciativa apasionante,
cuya misión es establecer el primer Ethiopian Community Exchange, [Intercambio de la Comunidad Etíope] o ECX
El intentercambio de materias primas en sí, ese concepto,
no es nuevo al mundo.
De hecho, en 1848, 82 comerciantes y agricultores de grano se reunieron
en un pequeño pueblo que se encuentra al cruce del Lago Illinois y el Lago Michigan
para establecer una manera de comerciar mejor entre sí .
Eso fuem por supuesto, el nacimiento del Chicago Board of Trade,
que es el intercambio de materias primas más famoso del mundo.
El Chicago Board of Trade fue establecido entonces
por precisamente las mismas razones
por las que los agricultores de hoy se beneficiarían de un intercambio de materias primas.
En la región norcentral de los EE UU, los agricultores solían cargar grano en barcazas
y mandarlo río arriba al mercado de Chicago.
Pero una vez que llegaba, si no había comprador,
o si de repente descendían los precios, los agricultores sufrían pérdidas tremendas.
Y de hecho, hasta tiraban el cereal al Lago Michigan,
en vez de tener que gastar más dinero transportándolo a sus granjas.
La necesidad de evitar estos riesgos enormes y pérdidas tremendas
condujo al surgimiento del mercado de futuros, y el sistema subyacente
de evaluar el cereal y de recibos de proporcionar recibos de depósito en almacén
sobre las base de los cuales se podría comerciar.
De ahí, surgió la innovación más grande de este mercado
que consiste en que los compradores y vendedores podían hacer transacciones
sin tener que inspeccionar el cereal física o visualmente.
Esto quería decir que se podía comerciar grano a través de distancias enormes,
y hasta a través del tiempo, hasta 18 meses en el futuro.
La innovación está en el seno de la transformación de la agricultura norteamericana
y el auge de Chicago en que la ciudad se hizo un mercado mundial,
mercado agrícola, una superpotencia comparado con donde estaba, una pequeña ciudad.
A lo largo del último siglo,
tenemos la tendencia de pensar en el intercambio de materias primas como el ámbito
de países industrializados del mundo occidental.
Y el hecho de que los precios de referencia para el algodón, el café, el cacao,
mayoritariamente productos del sur,
sean de verdad un precio de referencia, o un precio determinado en estos
intercambios oraganizados de materias primas en los países del norte.
Pero eso está cambiando.
Y somos testimonios de un cambio,
que funciona en gran parte a causa de la tecnología de la información.
Un cambio en la dominancia del mercado hacia los mercados emergentes.
Y a lo largo de la última década, ha sido obvio que el porcentaje de intercambios occidentales
es decir, el porcentaje de intercambios que pertenecen a los EE UU en el mundo,
ha disminuído casi al 50 por ciento en la última década.
De manera semejante, ha habido crecimiento explosive en la India, pr ejemplo
donde los hombres del campo están usando los intercambios, aumentándose
a lo largo de los últimos tres años hasta el 270 por ciento al año.
Esto se propulsa por tecnología VSAT de bajo costo,
que se esfuerza por llegar a los agricultores para trasladarlos al mercado.
El Intercambio de materias primas Dalian de China, hace tres años--
en 2004-- Adelantó la Junta de Comercio de Chicago para convertirse en
en el segundo mayor intercambio de materias primas del mundo.
Ahora, en Etiopía, estamos diseñando
el primer intercambio organizado de materias primas.
No estamos tratando de cortar y pegar el modelo de Chicago
o el de la India, sino que estamos creando un sistema que está hecho a la medida de
de las necesidades y realidades de Etiopía,
de los pequeños agricultores del país.
Bueno, el ECX es un intercambio etíope para Etiopía.
Estamos creando un sistema que sirve a todos los actores del mercado.
Eso crea integridad, fidelidad, eficacia, transparencia
y permite que los pequeños agricultores manejen los riesgos que he descrito.
En el diseño de nuestro intercambio de materias primas en Etiopía,
hemos hecho algo bien único, hemos decidido
abordar la situación desde una perspectiva integrada,
desde lo que llamamos el Borde ECX.
Básicamente el Borde ECX crea el ecosistema entero
en el cual se desarrollará el mercado.
Y es porque una de las cosas que hemos aprendido
a lo largo de una década de estudiar el desarrollo del mercado en África
es que una aproximación poco sistemática no funciona.
Hay un donante que se esfuerza por desarrollar la información del mercado,
otro que se esfuerza por desarrollar o subvencionar grados y estándares
otro ICT, y hasta otro por depósitos-- o recibo de depósitos en almacén .
En nuestra aproximación en Etiopía,
hemos optado por crear el ecosistema o medio ambiente
entero, en el que tiene lugar el comercio.
Eso quiere decir que el intercambio pondrá en marcha un sistema de comercio,
que empezará inicialmente como una protesta abierta.
Porque no creemos que el país esté listo para hacer todo el comercio electrónicamente.
Pero al mismo tiempo, vamos a hacer algo que no creo que ha hecho
ningún intercambio en el mundo, operar de manera semejante a
un cibercafé en los áreas rurales.
Para que los pequeños agricultores y comerciantes
puedan venir a un centro terminal, lo que llamamos
centros terminales para computación de acceso remoto, y en realidad,
sin tener que comprar una computadora o acceder al Internet por red telefónica
o cualquier de estas cosas, simplemente observan el comercio
que está pasando en el parqué de Addis Abeba.
Al mismo tiempo, lo fundamental de este mercado es que,
y repito, ésta es una innovación que hemos diseñado para nuestro intercambio,
es que el intercambio tendrá efecto en los depósitos de todo el país,
en los cuales se harán la certificación de estándares y el recibo de depósitos en almacén.
Y también vamos a operar un sistema de compensación en casa,
para asegurar que los pagos se hagan de manera apropiada,
en la cantidad correcta y a la hora correcta,
así que básicamente creamos fidelidad e integridad en el sistema.
Obviamente, trabajamos con actores de intercambio,
y a medida que desarrollamos el mercado de intercambio en sí,
también estamos desarrollando la infraestructura reguladora y el esquema legal,
el esquema legal dominante para hacer funcionar este mercado.
Así que de hecho nuestra proclamación
va al parlamento el próximo mes.
Lo que es muy importante es que el ECX operará un sistema de información del mercado
para diseminar precios a tiempo real a agricultores de todo el país,
usando la tecnología VSAT para llevar una diseminación electrónica de precios
directamente a los agricultores.
Lo que hace es transformar, de manera fundamental,
la relación que tienen los agricultores con el mercado.
Mientras que antes el agricultor pensaba localmente,
lo que significaba que él o ella iría al mercado local más cercano,
una distancia de entre ocho y 10 kilómetros por término medio,
y vender cualquier cosa que tenían en ese momento,
sin ninguna idea de lo que era la prima de precios ni nada,
ahora vienen con conocimientos de los precios en el mercado nacional.
Y se ponen a pensar en lo nacional, y hasta en lo global.
Empiezan a tomar no sólo las decisiones de marketing comercial,
sino también las de cultivo basándose en la información
que les viene del mercado de futuros de precios.
Y vienen al mercado conscientes de cuales grados lograrán
sus productos en términos de una prima de precios.
Así que todo esto transformará a los agricultores.
También va a transformar la manera de negociar de los comerciantes.
Dejarán de hacer recompras y arbitrajes limitados
y empezarán a pensar estratégicamente en cómo mover el cereal
a través de largas distancias desde los áreas de déficit hasta las regiones excedentes.
¿Es Etiopía capaz de esto?
Parece muy ambicioso.
Pero seguro que va a crear nuevas oportunidades.
Creemos que se requiere una gran voluntad política para lograr esta iniciativa,
y tendremos que alinear el sector financiero así como el ICT,
y en realidad hasta el esquema legal subyacente.
Creemos que la sociedad está por cambiar y que podemos hacerlo.
ECX es el mercado para el nuevo milenio de Etiopía,
que va a empezar dentro de unos ocho meses.
El último parlamento de nuestro siglo se abrió con el anuncio de nuestro presidente
cuando declaró al país que ésta era la iniciativa económica
más importante para la Etiopía de hoy.
Creemos que hay mucho en juego,
pero que las recompensas serán más grandes de lo que prodemos imaginar.
Además, el ECX podría convertirse en una plataforma de comercio para un mercado panafricano
de materias primas agrícolas.
El mercado doméstico de Etiopía vale aproximadamente mil milliones de dólares.
Y creemos que a lo largo de los próximos cinco años,
si Etopía puede capturar el 40 por ciento, sólo el 40 por ciento del mercado doméstico
y aumentar el valor de ese mercado el 25 por ciento, el valor del mercado se dobla.
El mercado agrícola de Etiopía es el 30 por ciento más grande
que la producción de cereal en Sudáfrica,
y de hecho, Etiopía es el segundo mayor productor de maíz de África.
Entonces el potencial está ahí
La voluntad está ahí.
El compromiso está ahí.
Creemos que tenemos una propuesta de valor que va a funcionar,
para transformar las opciones de los agricultores, para desarrollar nuestro sector,
y para cambiar África.
Así que estamos en el proceso de encontrar nuestra felicidad.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)